françois legault c'est qu'il s'aventure
sur un terrain sensible mieux des
personnes qu'il pensent que le mot privé
c'est comme si on parlait du diable de
qu'à cela ne tienne il veut créer des
centres médicaux privés des mines et
hôpitaux en quelque sorte où la
population pourrait obtenir des rendez
vous médicaux des chirurgies d'un jour
et se faire traiter pour des urgences
mineures le but désengorger le réseau
public si on était capable d'enlever le
plus possible les pétro au p4 5 qui
viennent à l'urgence puisqu'il devrait
pas être non on diminuerait de 30 à 40 %
l'achalandage dans les urgences des
normes d'ici 2025 la cac qui voudrait
que deux centres privés voit le jour 1a
québec l'autre dans l'est de montréal à
terme elle en voudrait une dizaine dans
la province le mot en paix n'est plus
tabou au québec croyez le ou non depuis
que le parti conservateur en a parlé
hier en conférence de presse hormis pour
éric duhaime qui promet encore plus de
place au privé l'idée passe mal chez les
adversaires de la cac le seul moment où
l'on considère le privé en santé c'est
pour accélérer les chirurgies que je
pense que françois legault est tombé en
amour avec le privé puis dans ce que
l'amour rend aveugle ça s'en va vers une
dégradation programmée des services
publics mais pour certains citoyens le
débat public privé importe peu ils
veulent des soins de qualité - j'aime
mieux faire le public en premier mais si
on est mal pris sauf que c'est une bonne
chose moi j'aime à 88 ans qui
nécessitent de plus en plus de soins et
les retards les délais dans le secteur
public sont très difficile humainement
très difficile à ceux qui craignent que
ces mini hôpitaux privés offrent de
meilleures conditions de travail
françois legault assure qu'il n'y aura
pas d'exode du personnel les urgences -
est ouvert 24 heures sur 24 les gmf de 8
à 8 7 jours sur 7 donc pas différent de
ce qu'on a dans le public puis la
qualité des soins vont être surveillés
même si les centres sera gérée et
construit grâce à des fonds privés
françois legault promet une chose les
soins eux seraient remboursés par la
régie de l'assurance maladie les
citoyens n'auraient donc pas à les payer
de leur propre poche ici alexandre duval
radio-canada coteau du lac